vietnam erneut verseuchte aufdeckung
gibt es ab heute für eine weile jeden
tag news für euch schreibt mir bitte wie
es findet wir sind so aktueller und ihr
findet videos zu themen auch einfacher
vorschläge von euch sind natürlich wie
immer gerne gesehen fangen wir aber
jetzt mal direkt mit der ersten user der
vietnamkrieg ist ja wirklich jedem ein
begriff dass vietnams im jahr 2016
erneut von einer gigantischen menge gift
wie damals in vietnam krieg betroffen
wurde das ist allerdings kaum jemand mal
was passiert im betroffenen küstengebiet
der regionen hat in london und tokio und
country haben zahlreiche fabriken ihrem
standort darunter unter anderem auch das
stahlwerk formosa viel hat hin
dieses ist zugleich auch der ursprung
allen übels mit 16 kam es dort zu
einigen merkwürdigen ereignissen
innerhalb kürzester zeit wurden 277
tonnen fischkadaver ans festland
gespielt auch in künstlich angelegten
fischzuchten ereignete sich ein
massensterben der deutsche chemiker dr
friedhelm schröder der vor ort im
einsatz ist erklärt dass in red dam
viele fabriken ihre abwässer ungeklärt
ableiten damit war relativ schnell klar
wie du eines der haupt lebensmittel der
vietnamesen in diesen ausmaßen verenden
konnte eben die fische unternommen wurde
aber erst mal nicht zitat anstatt die
öffentlichkeit von der umweltkatastrophe
zu informieren und die bevölkerung vor
den gesundheitsgefahren zu warnen
zerschlug die vietnamesische regierung
proteste mitunter brutal und ließ
demonstranten festnehmen
anstatt den schutz von umwelt und
bevölkerung ernst zu nehmen und
entsprechende existierende gesetze in
der praxis umzusetzen wird wieder nur
nach halbleitenden lösungen gesucht so
die deutsche stiftung meeresschutz kurz
wer denn eigentlich sollte die lage in
vietnam anders sein
für den geltenden gesetzen gehören
nämlich unter anderem auch regelmäßige
kontrollen der abwasser einrichtung hier
wird allerdings oft einfach nur dreist
geschummelt kommt es zu einer kontrolle
wird sehr oft eine leitung geprüft die
für solche kontrollen
vorgesehen und dementsprechend in
ordnung ist die leitung die
tatsächlichen betrieb sind werden
hingegen oft aber einfach verschwiegen
und von überprüfungen damit
ausgeklammert so gescheit wohl auch bei
dem stahlwerk von moser stil hat hin
in der mitteilung der dsm halb sie tat
das meereswasser ist mit phaeno zenit
und eifel hydroxyl verseucht wie die
schließlich nicht zuletzt aufgrund des
zunehmenden drucks durch nationale und
internationale proteste mit der
untersuchung beauftragten in und
ausländischen experten herausfanden
die aus ungeklärten abwässern von
formosa stil stammenden gifte haben das
marine ökosystem zerstört
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass es
mindestens 50 jahre dauern wird bis sich
wieder erholt hat er wirklich eine
ziemliche katastrophe ja und empfiehlt
den fischern auch die lebensgrundlage
wenn es euch gefällt ab jetzt täglich
eine news von uns zu bekommen dann lasst
hier gerne einen daumen nach oben da
euer feedback in den kommentaren und ein
kosten- und abo dafür einfach hier
klicken wir sehen uns dann also schon
morgen wieder biss dann bleibt dran